All right.
So, the last topic I'd like to cover in
palm DP land is a line of work
that that I am somewhat fond of,
that is called predictive
state representation.
So let me let me say a little bit about
the motivation behind studying this, and
we'll talk a little bit about
the representation itself.
But we're not going to talk much
about algorithms that actually make
use of this.
There is a literature
if you want to dive in.
All right.
So,
here's the basic premise
of this line of work.
So, we talk about POMDPs.
So, POMDPs, when we're moving around in
a POMDP we're tracking the belief state,
which is a distribution over states,
right?
>> Right.
So, here's the thing.
The states are not observable, right?
>> Right.
So,
how can we ever thought
hope to learn in a PomDP,
when we never actually get to
see these underlying states?
They're never observed.
So, you could ask yourself
do they even exist, or
are they just kind of useful
fictions of our imagination?
There's nothing that we
can ever do to test hey,
was this the state we were actually in?
The answer is I don't know.
I mean, if we're learning in a POMDP,
we're just creating this notion of
states to provide some structure to
the observations that we've seen.
>> Is this like a tree
in the forest thing?
>> Yeah, yeah.
If a POMDP is solved in a forest,
does anybody know whether or
not they exist?
And the answer is me.
>> No, I think you're right.
I mean, we're making this
stuff up anyway, right?
>> Yeah.
And in the case that
somebody gives us a POMDP and
says would you please plan in this,
it's a reasonable
representation to work with.
But if you're in a reinforcement
learning setting,
you never get to see
these underlying states.
You can never actually collect
statistics about them.
In fact, most of the good work
that I've seen that uses POMDPs,
they don't learn the POMDP.
They actually send, I want to say
grad students out into the field
to measure underlying states, and
then measure the observation function.
They actually kind of instrument
the world to build a POMDP,
and then they can act in
the POMDP successfully later.
But it's just there's really no
good way to learn about the states.
>> Or even that they're real even.
>> Eve that they're real.
>> Okay.
So, now that you've blown my mind,
what does it have to do with?
>> Right.
So, so,
the idea of a predictive
state representation,
or P.S.R., is that the thing that we're
going to use for representation isn't
going to be probability distributions
over these possibly fictional states.
But instead,
they're going to be probabilities of
the outcomes of future predictions.
So, I'm in a state where it's about 80%
chance it's going to rain tomorrow.
>> Okay.
Which doesn't require an actual state.
>> Well, and
that is maybe not a great example.
So, let me give a more concrete example
to kind of ground this idea out.